[Music]
this week on
forward here we are we we have a new
virus we don't know what causes it we
don't know much about it we don't know
how to treat it we don't even really
know how to diagnose it we don't have
any of those problems when we talk about
schizophrenia depression bipolar illness
we know how to we know how to diagnose
these illnesses and we know how to treat
them it's the execution how do you get
the things that people need to them when
they need it and the right way I think
the reason we do is we confuse illness
and identity and it's an easy mistake to
make as I write about in the book you
know these are people who have made that
mistake for themselves they may think
that schizophrenia is who they are and
what we're doing here when we allow
someone to stay under the bridge is
we're listening to their illness and not
paying attention to their
[Music]
identity I am thrilled to have joining
me on the podcast today the former
director of the National Institute of
Mental Health the former mental health
Zar for the State of California member
of the National Academy of Sciences
psychiatrist neuroscientist and author
of the book healing our path from mental
illness to mental health Tom inel MD Tom
welcome thank you Andrew what a pleasure
to be here I was going to wear my math
hat this morning decided I'd leave it
off just because it's kind of dated but
um delighted to be sitting down with you
having this conversation well delighted
as well uh and so you know um you met my
brother at a particular point because
he's a psychologist um you were the
director of the NIH and he was just an
assistant professor who was writing
grants in your direction he
actually got got some grants which great
um which excited our parents a great
deal but uh tell people a little bit I
think people mostly vaguely know what
the national Institute of Mental Health
is um you were essentially the Surgeon
General for the mental health of the
country for gosh over a decade uh yeah
usually people would say the Tony fouchy
of mental health because it's the
parallel position that so the uh Tony
and 26 others of us U are Institute
directors within the vast thing called
the National Institutes of Health and
that's part of the Department of Health
and Human Services and the federal
government and it's it's it's really an
interesting uh agency which the
government essentially has put several
billion dollars into research on um
biomed and public health issues so the
Institute of National Institute of
Mental Health was the government's
investment in in science to understand
more about everything from the most
basic aspects of mental illness like how
does the brain work and what are the
genetics some these disorders and where
in the brain can you see the impact to
um how do you develop Diagnostics and
Therapeutics and even tracking um the
epidemiology and you know how common are
these and where do they occur and all of
that stuff so it's um for now what 75
years um it's been the U really the
flagship in the United States for
understanding mental illness what it
doesn't do it used to do until 1991
guess is it was also involved with the
service delivery system uh so it it was
the National Institute of Mental Health
that led the Community Mental Health
movement of the 1960s and70s under
President Kennedy and then Johnson and
and thereafter but uh that was split off
there's another agency in the federal
government called samsa substance abuse
mental health Services Agency that's
responsible for the services side of
delivering care um and provides money to
all the states to do much of that so
this book is a passion project of yours
and I love it so much because uh imagine
the guy who is running uh point for
science on mental health and you tell
this very jarring story but it's very
personal where you're um doing a talk
and you're talking about the science of
mental health and then a dad stands up
and is like hey um the house is on fire
because he has a child who's suffering
from schizophrenia or an acute mental
illness and you here talking about the
chemistry of the paint and I I thought
that that was such uh like a an honest
uh depiction of and then you know you
you um like are are um now uh very open
about the fact that what's motivating
you is look we know some of the things
that are working and not working in
mental health uh and and yet we're
suffering at an epic level that parent
um your book is filled with very
personal stories about people who are
suffering from mental health issues and
a lot of them don't have Happy Endings
too that's that's another thing that um
you know I I thought was very very
honest um so what drove you to write
this
book yeah you know Andrew was really
just that disconnect for me I I had
been um kind of on the bridge you know
driving this ship on research and it was
phenomenal I mean I really feel
privileged to have been from 2002 to 20
helping hundreds including your brother
uh thousands of of scientists make
phenomenal advances it really was this
kind of Golden Era for Neuroscience for
genomics for many areas of basic science
especially actually cognitive science
and Behavioral Science where we really
went from um I would say kind of a
plateau for many many years to um a
completely different space within those
13 years it was it was spectacular so on
the one hand um I saw all this progress
and I know from that experience that you
know we knew more we had more to offer
we had more people getting into
treatment and yet when you look at the
population statistics you look at
population Health all the numbers were
going south y you you know you could see
the suicide rate increased 30% in those
years suicide death rate in the United
States uh the number of people with
serious mental illnesses like
schizophrenia bipolar illness and severe
depression who were becoming homeless
becoming unemployed um becoming
incarcerated which is kind of so hard
for us to understand in this country and
yet it's what we do all that was getting
so much worse so I couldn't
really I I like it was like A Tale of
Two Cities I couldn't put them together
I couldn't figure out like how how is it
that so much of our progress in science
has failed to move the needle in public
health what are we doing wrong here how
I mean literally have we failed because
it was failure and it was our inability
to deliver on what we know which is very
different than the problem in much of
medicine where we don't know what we
need to do here we actually had good
things to offer people don't often
understand that but for virtually every
mental disorder we have treatments that
work if you get them in the right way at
the right time and it's the right
treatment for you you'll do well people
do recover um and yet with all of that
um the statistics and they don't lie in
this case because you see this with your
own eyes in every city and even in rural
areas of America today people are
suffering far more than they had been
before yeah the the data is not good uh
and you referenced suicides which I
think most people are familiar with
anxiety depression um all going up uh it
sounds like you're looking at a time
period that's beyond the kind of recent
what they call like the young person
epidemic though that there are a lot of
folks who think that uh it's more
pronounced among uh younger generation
perhaps because of social media and uh
and other forces um so there there's a
press conference you relate early in the
book you talk about uh so someone says
hey uh the mental health system in
America is broken and there are a lot of
people that say that uh in different
context in the book it's like oh the the
mental health system in America is
broken and then someone uh I believe it
was the then Surgeon General corrects
and says um you're wrong because America
doesn't actually have a national mental
health system um and I thought that that
was a very important observation or
characterization so for the average
American listening to this they're they
think hey it seems like our mental
health is getting worse and then they
also think uh that there are a bunch of
structural reasons why it might be very
hard to to get treatment which we'll go
into and your book happily documents
them um but first is there actually a
national mental health
system no you know I think there was
when I was I'm an old guy so I started
training uh in the 70s when we had a
community mental health system and there
really was a national system funded by
the federal government set up through
the Kennedy administration it was
actually the last bill that he signed
before he was assassinated almost
precisely to the day 30 years ago I'm
sorry 60 years ago um end of
October and when he signed the
bill uh he made this famous statement uh
just outside the oal office where he was
doing his signing ceremony he said you
know um we're in a new era and with what
we know today uh we can do so much
better he said that people with mental
illness must no longer be alien to our
affections or apart from our communities
and he laid out this beautiful Vision uh
that we would build a national Mental
Health Care System um funded by the
federal government that every Community
would have a clinic um where people
would be able to get the new medications
because we just had the first
antipsychotics um they would be able to
leave the state hospitals where many on
average people had stayed for a decade
so it was a really long length of stay
it's hard to believe uh there were
600,000 people like that in the United
States at that time his vision was that
they would be in these Community clinics
where there would be wraparound services
and they would be able to thrive and
recover um that so we did have a
national mental health system when I
started my career and I do think we
actually did better for people at that
point uh but that ended in 1980 well
actually to be fair it never really got
built out fully uh the vision was there
I don't think the implementation was we
screwed up as we often do in America we
screwed up on the execution so what what
ended up happening was that uh people
left the state hospital State hospitals
closed we have 95% fewer beds in state
hospitals today than we did when I
started my career 50 years ago but um we
didn't really provide the community
supports and we didn't have um all of
the services that people needed uh to be
able to thrive outside of an institution
hence homelessness incarceration we sort
of what I call in the book we we went
into not just
deinstitutionalization but
transinstitutionalization we move people
from a state hospital system to jails
and prisons and and and the criminal
justice system is is to the extent that
there is a national mental health system
today it's it's a statun and locally run
jail and prison system and I you know
obviously we don't do that for diabetes
we don't do it for hypertension we don't
do it for asthma but in the case of
mental illness um it's become a criminal
criminal justice issue not a it's no
longer so much a healthcare issue yeah
there there's a graph in the book that
uh very vividly shows uh the decline of
State Mental Hospitals and then the
massive construction of prisons and
jails uh and it's almost uh one to one
um it it's wild um so how many mentally
ill people do you think are behind bars
as we're having this conversation
roughly yeah the number that we usually
look at according to treatment Advocacy
Center who looked at this is about
345,000 people every night or in a jail
or a prison uh because they have a
serious mental illness and they've done
something which is part of their illness
um so these
aren't essentially I mean they may have
done criminal activity but they're the
kind of people who in the early part of
my career would have ended up in a
hospital um where they' be treated not
behind bars where um they would really
often just languish I mean to be fair I
you know this isn't it's not like
sheriffs and and prison wardens are
looking to do this this isn't what they
want to be doing either no no it's just
it's Fallen to them uh I talk about this
in the book you know I walked around U
the San Francisco jail I live in the Bay
Area and um I took a day when I was
working on the book uh to spend in that
jail and and it was just it just blew my
mind that there was I think I tell the
story I walked around with a nurse who
was handing out medication at every cell
and she had a medication cart exactly
like what we used to use in the hospital
going from you know room to room and
handing out whatever medication was on
the chart that's what they do in jails
today um and um and the numbers are
really are really disturbing when you
look at uh how long people stay in jails
because and by the way often these are
not people who have necessarily
committed a crime you know they're
waiting to be adjudicated often so they
could be there for months because if
you're a person with a psychotic illness
um you're probably not going to be the
first one to be processed and and the
numbers are really stunning it's not
only that they stay longer but they stay
they come more often they have a much
more frequent rate of being processed
through the the jail system so it
literally has become the def fault
Mental Health Care system for this 14
million people who have serious mental
illness uh it's an exceptional thing
there's I don't know of any other
country that does that um it's
incredibly expensive it's not what
anybody wants and yet it's where We've
Ended up because we don't have the
capacity to do this in a way that where
they're no longer alien to our
affections they're no longer part of our
communities
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a pretty short list of things you
can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people do the math for night free
trial you can sleep on this thing for 3
months it will keep you cool don't just
take my word for it my kids seek out
this mattress in the house it's the
number one rated mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yangang this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now so we closed all the state hospitals
and then if I have uh a friend or
relative or child uh who is experiencing
mental health issues uh then it's very
very hard to get them into treatment um
often times they don't want treatment
you can't commit someone else to
treatment if you do try and bring them
to treatment there might not be a bed
available for them because uh certainly
the state hospitals don't have beds you
do describe in the book where there are
beds available um in private facilities
but often they're uncovered uh because
if someone doesn't have health insurance
then they don't get that even if you do
have health insurance they cover you a
finite number of days and then they uh
they're like and you're out of here and
they be like out to where and then
people are like don't know and and then
in some cases if you have money maybe
they bring you to some other facility uh
that's uh paid for out out of pocket
there are heartbreaking stories of
families going broke trying to fund
their child's treatment um whatnot
sometimes that treatment's not effective
so like if you go into the the system it
ends up being this uh broken uncovered
underresourced hodge podge um and you're
you're not sure uh and uh and so a lot
of people slip through the cracks and
then they wind up um in our criminal
justice system or in some cases homeless
so so that's the the thing that I think
most Americans believe uh to be true
like how much of of that description
some of that description is drawn from
your book how much of that description
is um is the the
reality yeah I think it's pretty close
and and of course it depends uh where
you come in to the system and what
resources you have there are people who
can pay for private Care at a very nice
facility and get reasonably good care
but that's the 1% uh most of us aren't
going to be in that situation and even
those places there could be a long
waiting list to get in I mean we just
don't have the capacity we have to
rebuild that and I wouldn't want anybody
listening to think that the book is only
about how crappy the situation is
because it is pretty you know it's
pretty dire but actually most of the
book's about Solutions cuz I'm you know
I actually am really optimistic that
these are all problems everything you
just mentioned Andre we can actually we
can fix that these are not insolvable or
even that difficult of problems to fix
and kind of what one of the things that
Drew me to to write the book was to
realize wait a second like this is I was
working on this at uh very beginning of
Co and I thought wait I mean like here
we are we we have a new virus we don't
know what causes it we don't know much
about it we don't know how to treat it
we don't even really know how to
diagnose it uh we don't have any of
those problems when we talk about
schizoph FIA depression bipolar illness
we know how to we know how to diagnose
these illnesses and we know how to treat
them and and the real issue is uh kind
of again I said before it's the
execution how do you get the things that
people need to them when they need it in
the right way um it's not easy always
but U it's not an impossible problem to
solve and so but I'm I I'm actually
pretty optimistic that U we're we're
turning the corner on a lot of those
issues that you just described and some
of them are going to be hard but
technology helps us a ton um it
democratizes care it allows us to do
things much more efficiently it's all
kinds of ways in which it improves
access it also allows us to measure
objectively AI is going to be
transformative for this field and it's
going to allow us to improve quality of
care by getting better measurement which
has been a huge huge problem um
medications you know are important and
they're a big part of this but what I
talk a lot about in the book is that
it's not enough medications may be
necessary but not sufficient for what we
really need which isn't just reducing
symptoms but helping people recover
helping them to get the housing the work
support the family support all the
things that they're going to need if
they're going to thrive and they do you
know you give them those things they do
Thrive and and we have
to we really have to remember that that
um the goal here is recovery and people
do recover and we know how to help them
but what we don't know is um how to get
that at scale well I agree your book is
very very Solutions oriented Solutions
packed uh and uh I I learned a lot um so
uh let's talk about what works and
here's some of the heartening things
where you dig in say let's say someone's
suffering from depression which I I
think is the most widespread um there
are things that work uh you talked about
medications uh some of them uh work on a
lot of people uh maybe they have to try
different things um you uh make a case
for cognitive behavioral therapy which
is something that uh I'm a huge fan of
um and it works uh now it now it turns
out that um a relatively low proportion
of the people that would benefit from
getting cognitive behavioral therapy
actually receive it um which is
unfortunate um but we know that it's
effective in a very significant uh
number of cases one thing that that's
where technology sorry but that's that's
a place where technology can help the
fact that um you can make this available
to far more people online than we can
brick and mortar yeah so that's super
exciting there was one thing that blew
my mind which was fun um which was that
uh that there's uh magnetic stimulation
um that actually has been proven to help
ease depression in a number of people
and um you have a case study where a
woman's like what and then does does
some transal Med stimulation it's like
oh my gosh that actually does make me
feel something uh you know a little bit
better so there's there are things that
work um unfortunately not enough people
are getting them for a variety of
reasons yeah so what I I talk a lot in
the book
about this idea that we have to shift
from a kind of strictly medical model
the pill or the magnetic stimulation or
whatever it is uh to a broader model
that looks at at supporting recovery and
I and I talk a lot about that as the
three PS people place in purpose that um
unlike the treatment of cancer where
we're or an infectious disease where
we're you know you got a simple bug out
there and you want to kill it with a
simple drug you do that you're done it
it's just not like that here here for
most people particularly those with a
serious mental illness like
schizophrenia it's going to require a
lot more and that to give giving people
the threepiece people place and purpose
the social support the the environment
in which they can recover and then and a
purpose a reason something to something
to recover for something to strive for a
mission um we don't have to do that in
most of medicine but we do have to do
that here and and I think when I wrote
the
book and I was so focused on this um I
left out a pee I didn't really
understand it until later and that was
payment we don't pay for much of what
really matters and what really is
important for people to recover and
without the payment it doesn't get done
at least not in the Health Care system
so as you were saying you know what why
is it that people don't get the care
don't get the things that work it's
because we don't really incentivize that
so we have a we have a set of problems
that require this very broad approach um
and yet we do this within a healthcare
context where we take a very narrow kind
of infectious disease
approach um and even in the world that I
come from which is the world of science
and research so much of our research was
in search of that
the next penicillin for schizophrenia
that that magic bullet that was going to
make all the difference I don't know
that that's really ever going to happen
but I do know that if we get away from
that magic bullet kind of thinking and
say we're going to make
sure that Mr Jones has has the social
support he needs he has the environment
he needs and he has the help with work
getting back to work um that he'll be
able to recover and he's obviously going
to need to be on medication most of the
time so all of that is actually possible
if we start to pay for it um and you
know the the irony of all this is that
it's not very expensive um the things
that I write about in the book are like
the clubhouse you know New York has a
wonderful clubhous called Fountain
house for 75 years people have been
uh helped with helping each other I to
be really clear it's about people
helping each other to recover and and it
works it really matters um and you can
replicate that all across the country um
that's not a very expensive operation um
and yet it does the work
that greatly reduces rehospitalization
emergency room visits all that stuff the
other amazing thing that's sort of
happened since the book was written um
and I i' love to think that the book
helped in this um is that we have as a
nation decided to recreate a national
Nal Mental Health Care System the first
time since
1963 so the bipartisan safer communities
Act of last
year decided that uh we're in a national
crisis in terms of mental health the
White House says that the Surgeon
General says that we have to do
something and so they took a model
called
the oh it's a terrible name the
certified community behavioral health
centers or
ccbhcs uh which were already going in a
few States as a pilot program and they
said this is fantastic this really works
we have now the initial data um and
these are these are centers that provide
the 3ps they they provide for uh all the
things that we need we know people need
to recover whole person care
irrespective of age geography ability to
pay or diagnosis as long as people have
either substance use disorder or a
serious mental illness they're in they
get care here and they get care that's
completely WRA around all the things
that they're going to need it's not just
medication and we're going to we're
going to fund that we're going to fund
that across the country we're going to
put 85 billion dollars into that and
we're going to make sure um that we do
this in a way that really begins to bend
the curve for um this population which
has ended up
incarcerated instead of in the Health
Care system so once again these folks
are no longer going to be alien to our
affections we'll see um I'm I'm
concerned that we need to make sure we
learned the lessons of the 60s and 70s
when we last tried to do this but how
cool is this that just in the last year
year and a half the country has uh begun
to wake up to really saying no we're
going to try to do this at scale
hey YouTube thanks for watching please
do hit like And subscribe and hit that
Bell if you want to be notified every
time a new episode drops probably on
Mondays but hit that Bell and thank
you yeah their book is very wise um and
it it talks about the whole patient
approach of it does have the three PS
people place and purpose and it goes
into things that have been constructive
that when and what's good too is you're
honest you're like initially you were
like that works and you're like yeah it
does work so it it's things like um
supportive grandmas where they're
they're like reaching out to the
Friendship bench yeah that's right yeah
the Friendship bench I was like that
works um I mean you know but then you
think oh yeah that would work cuz it's
just human you know like you have people
reaching out to you um you have nurses
taking over care in a particular way and
then that that uh works wonders and
you're like huh like that doesn't seem
that hard um so you there so there are a
bunch of things that are kind of obvious
in human uh you know and and you talk
about how the treatment is a small
fraction of uh the the problem um even
though even that's not you know
happening all the time obviously uh and
that there are all of these things
around the patient the environment uh
you know like the the
uh their ability to feel like there's a
reason to wake up in the morning you
know like get out and do things you know
and when you think about it's like oh
that seems pretty obvious but uh but
then that's not the way our sick care
system approaches things like you you
say they go in and be like oh you you
got accute symptoms let me try and zap
those symptoms and then you like put
them back into whatever the heck
environment and hope for the best and uh
and Shockers it's not very effective
yeah I was at a meeting yesterday where
somebody when I said we don't have a
mental healthare system he said of
course we have a system we have exactly
a system it's not broken he said it
works exactly the way it was set up to
work which is to be totally
dysfunctional it's actually you know
it's just it's incentivizing all the
wrong things and um and I think that's
that's right I think we could fix this
simply by starting to move the money
towards what the things we want so um
you mentioned that I served as a mental
health Zar in California and um I didn't
get very much done that was in 2019 but
my God what's happened since then here
is just stunning and it's a story that I
don't think most people would
know um we have a governor who uh cares
deeply about these issues and I'm not I
don't work for him so I don't have to
say any of this but he's become pretty
unpopular with parts of the advocacy
movement because he's um demanding
accountability and he's demanding that
we close that Gap that I started with
the gap between what we know and what we
do because you know he's just so fed up
with the fact that in spite of spending
so much money in California on mental
health issues we have more homeless
people more people with untreated mental
illness more people getting
incarcerated and so he's basically said
enough already and we've done a bunch of
things here which I think are are first
in the nation and are pretty
extraordinary so we revamped our
Medicaid system Medicaid is the health
insurance the public health insurance
for people
um who can't afford private insurance so
it's it's um the major payer for mental
health care in across the country and uh
and certainly within
California we we've gotten a waiver for
how we use the Medicaid money so we have
today the ability for a Medicaid
provider in our state to write a to do
all three PS um if I'm a Medicaid
provider I can write a prescription for
food I can write a prescription for um
to you know help somebody with their
loneliness I can write a prescription
for rent how amazing is that so um the
people place and purpose idea has now
become not directly but but all of those
things are really within the purview of
what Medicaid can do for the first time
pretty stunning the other thing you
mentioned this before Andrew and it it's
often not clear to people who aren't
directly involved in this field but if
you have a loved one with severe mental
illness they're not looking for care
often uh they don't may they may not
even think that they're sick they may
deny being ill and that's such a huge
challenge because it throws you into
this problem that I write about in The
Book of involuntary treatment and uh you
know in America we don't like to talk
about this but for someone who has
dementia or sometimes for young children
who are too young to be able to
choose that they actually need to have
blood drawn to get a diagnosis or or for
someone with psychosis who says look um
yeah I'm I'm telling you there really
are aliens who are tracking my brain
waves and you just can't hear them but I
can and so I'm right and you're wrong um
those are people who may need to be
treated um in spite of their wishes and
we've been
very loathed to do that um and it's one
of the reasons why in California we have
so people living under bridges and
eating out of dumpsters is we don't want
to we don't want to confront them and
say look you're sick and you need to be
the compassionate thing here is to help
you even though you may not want the
help what we're doing is allowing people
to die with their rights on and the
governor has finally said maybe that's
not the most compassionate thing maybe
we need to actually mandate treatment
and we also need to mandate that the
counties provide the treatment for
people who may not be knocking on on
their door but who were living under
their Bridges I I yeah I I I think it's
I don't think it's compassionate just to
let someone die under the bridge uh you
know I don't think it's compassionate to
be uh stepping over people who are
clearly in in need of help as is
happening in a a lot of places uh I
think it's just um I mean you described
as a reluctance to confront um there are
various failures really institutional
failures uh and then people suffer as a
result including people who could use um
some help uh and your book really makes
a very powerful case like look we don't
allow this for diabetes or any other
type of illness like what the heck are
you know why are we treating this so
differently yeah I think I think the
reason we do is we confuse illness and
identity and it's an easy mistake to
make as I write about in the book you
know these are people who have made that
mistake for themselves they may think
that schizophrenia is who they are and
what we're doing here when we allow
someone to stay under the bridge is
we're listening to their illness and not
paying attention to their identity and
you know it maybe only 2% of that person
is the part that's going to recover it's
it but but it's still that 2% that
you've got to focus on the part of that
person that is not ill and it's I mean
for the
people who do this um and who spend the
time um trying to help those under a
bridge someplace and here where I live
in the Bay Area we have thousands and
thousands of people in this situation um
what you learn is they don't really want
to be living this way this isn't a
choice this isn't what they want to do
they're frightened um and they're
frightened because of the voices and and
they're frightened to go someplace where
they won't they don't know what's going
to happen to them uh and so
it's it's it's kind of Unthinkable that
we have allowed their illness to
become the part of them that we are
listening to instead of understanding
that there's a
person behind that illness who's
ultimately going to Triumph if they get
the right care but who um just doesn't
have the strength to do it by themselves
and so it does come down to compassion
and thinking about what is the most
compassionate issue but I bring this up
and I think it's important to talk about
it in the book because even though you
know in this conversation we're focused
on mental illness quickly you realize
wow this is at the center of so many
other things this is so many this is at
the center of homelessness of crowding
of the Jails of problems in schools of
just a huge number of issues I was with
some folks yesterday from the child
welfare system just stunning how you
know 35% of the kids in the child
welfare system are not going to graduate
from high school why is that a lot of
them have untreated mental illness that
just don't end up getting the services
they need so
it's it's really I think for so many of
the issues we care about um this has
been the piece that we just haven't
really addressed and haven't wanted to
deal with but we're going to have to I
call this in the book I call it our Jim
Crow moment because it is it does these
are are Untouchables in a way they're
our lowest cast they've been neglected
entirely and yet um it's it's not who we
are or maybe it is who we are but it's
not who we want to be and I think it's
you know what I'm arguing is that um we
could redefine the nation over how we
help those who are suffering the most
and who have the greatest
needs imagine running for president and
wanting to share what you experienced in
a way that's entertaining edifying and
maybe even a little bit scary that's the
last election out in book stores now a
novel about an independent presidential
candidate a journalist with a massive
story and what the heck could be our
nextlast election check it out at
andrewyang.com
[Music]
so your fourth P of payment I think is
super profound um uh and this is my
obsession in life now um For Better or
For Worse um which is that you get what
the system incentivizes you don't get
what the system doesn't incentivize uh
you talk about Fountain house um which
is a great org um Fountain House is a
nonprofit that uh raises money in
various ways they might get some Public
Funding but I think a lot of it's
philanthropic um which is something that
a lot of people understand it's like oh
you know like good causes and
organizations uh rise up um to fill in
needs uh I think most of us would uh
agree that they don't you know they
don't have the resources necessary to
fill all the needs and that you you'd
hope for in this case like more
functional institutions and that um but
in the absence of those institutions
there are various nonprofits doing great
work so how could we incentivize the
right things in this system um you know
it's like so my my obsession is it's
like hey you incentivize wacky politics
you get wacky politics uh you know
you you yeah you you would certifies
money flowing to treatment of symptoms
get some of that you know uh now you
talk about prevention in the book you
know we don't get much of that because
there's no money in that imagine a a
system that's built around paying for
people who have a diagnosis how do you
do prevention in that situation it's not
going to work so it's it's um it's
really the question right now that I'm
most consumed with I after doing the
book I co-founded a startup called Vana
health and Vana basically looks at
exactly this issue for the people who
are the most expensive those who are
going in and out of prison or jail those
who are in and out of emergency rooms or
inpatient
facilities uh it's really stunning
because even those who may not have um
be in the Behavioral Health Care System
they may not even you know ever go to a
mental health clinic they may have
serious mental illness and what's
driving them in and out are their
pulmonary problems their cardiac
problems they may have foot ulcers just
a whole bunch of things on the medical
side they're the among the most most
expensive medical patients and that was
my aha moment CU I thought holy moly we
can actually save a lot of money if we
just provide them the three PS if we
provide them decent uh care not just
health care but decent care U we can
keep them from ending up in the
emergency room uh every other week and
it works it's just stunning so this is a
a way in which you actually spend far
less money and you get much better
results Sals Fountain House is a
brilliant example of that I think um in
full disclosure I'm on the board it's a
you know place I care deeply about but
the numbers we have say that uh a year
within Fountain House is less expensive
than two weeks in the hospital so it's I
believe that there are ways to because
we all know what two weeks at hospital
might cost that's right or even you know
a typical e visit could be $5,000 or
more uh we you know you've got to figure
out a way to um to prevent that and you
can prevent it a lot of what drives
people into the emergency room are
things that a coach can manage in their
home or a community health worker can
manage in the community so um we don't
have to be doing it the way we've been
doing it um van has launched in
Philadelphia where we're just trying to
prove this out uh in the inner city and
neighborhoods where the Medicaid
population uh is incredibly expensive
we're spending a huge amount of taxpayer
money on this population
and getting just such funky outcomes so
we're we're interested in in um changing
those incentives changing how we pay for
this and using um the best data to
demonstrate that we can in fact get much
better outcomes for people we can get
them not just so that they're not in the
hospital or the emergency room but we
get them actually out of their homes uh
into club houses into
workplaces get them back with families
all the things that people really want
to do they really care about you know I
mentioned this in the book that if you
talk to people with schizophrenia 70
some per of them want to be working 10%
of them
work so they're incentivized they you
know they're motivated but they just
don't get the support and they don't get
the support because we don't support it
we don't pay for supportive employment
we know how to do this it's not that
complicated we've had the the evidence
base for this since the 1980s
um and yet U it's not something that
we've been paying for because it doesn't
really fit into the health care model in
the way
that we would do it with an infectious
disease well uh hats off to you for
trying to help folks who are you know I
mean it's obvious why you're focusing on
the people are most expensive because uh
that there's most opportunity for
savings but those people are I'm sure in
uh really really tough Straits and
environments and so anyone you can get
into a better environment it's a human
win and I'm I'm sure a massive cost
savings for everyone so you are uh an
adviser to the good life movement
started by our young friend Andrew
folley fans of the podcast U might
remember um him from a number of months
back so let's just play and and you're
you're a man after my own heart because
you wrote a book in hopes of catalyzing
a movement um I've been known to do
that so you you so so you so you you
wrote uh this excellent book thinking
hey guys look we actually know what
would work we need to drive things in
that direction you're now working on the
solution your yourself trying to channel
um more uh Market incentives towards
helping people in need so let's say
hypothetically um you were not just the
mental health Zar for California U but
the mental health Zar for the entire
country and you have a veritable magic
wand uh you have all members of Congress
together you have all the agencies
together you be like okay guys um uh
these are going to be my final acts as
yeah as um what would be on that that
bill uh and and I I and I hate to talk
about things in terms of legislation
because you know a lot of things you
talk about in the book it's like aren't
necessarily like I can legislate this
thing um but uh but you do have a whole
host of um Big Ideas that do feed into
policy which is naturally given uh where
where where you've been so what are like
the the end uh for so let's even imagine
it within the context of the good life
movement so the good life movement
becomes this uh thriving
popular wave where everyone's like yeah
like we want a system that actually is
going to make us uh mentally healthier
and our kids uh more optimistic about
the future and then the good life
movement and you um are able to do
whatever the heck you want like what
what what does that list look List look
like yeah so I think it takes us in a
little different conversation than the
one we've been having we've been really
talking about you how do you fix this
compl completely broken world that we're
in for people who have
schizophrenia you know the list that I
would start to put together moves way
Upstream from that and say I like it I'm
into it let's go I mean maybe You' have
something like everyone getting out of
poverty ah so now we're getting yeah so
that's exactly where I was going so I
think you want to think about yeah you
want to think about not just Universal
basic income but you want to think about
things like the nurse Family Partnership
this was a program set up again and imh
did this 50 years ago set up this this
program originally in Elmyra New York
and then it went to several other parts
of the country to prove it out um but
it's the idea that uh when uh people get
when women get pregnant particularly uh
women in marginalized communities they
have the support they have a nurse they
have somebody a coach who works with
them through the pregnancy uh and and
through the first year of um being a mom
so that they get the resources they need
they get the support they need if they
get depressed they get the treatment um
the evidence from this it's like the
evidence for Universal pre um this is
more effective in the long term than any
of our treatments in terms of getting
really remarkable reductions in
substance use disorder and involvement
with criminal justice system likelihood
to be on Medicaid I mean just it's it's
these are just very very impactful
programs that we have yet to scale
because we've yet to fund them actually
to be fair the Obama Administration
committed to taking that to scale but
they never really got it done in the
right way so it's um there's a whole
bunch of areas there I think we want to
think a lot more about how we and we're
doing this in California how we make
schools um the center of gravity for a
lot of what we can do in the mental
health space uh teaching kids resilience
uh I like the term future proofing
there's a whole movement called uh
social emotional learning in school
which is become politicized and
weaponized and it's not really the right
language but what it does is exactly
what we want to be able to do is in the
same way that we used to teach kids
about their physical health teaching
them the basics of their Mental Health
like how do you label emotions you kind
of you know we like to say you name it
to tame it how do you manage your
emotions how do you help uh what do you
do when you can't sleep um all these
things that are you know they're not
fuzzy they're really and yet yeah mental
hygiene but in a way that is um is is
fully uh adaptive and and effective in
Australia they've put together for every
Middle School kid in in New South Wales
is part of this program called future
proofing where they have an app on their
phone they have a wearable uh they
learned how to journal and to you know
use their app to sort of manage their
own emotional states there are some
digital Therapeutics in there they can
use if they want there's a whole series
of things that we can now do for a
generation that essentially lives in the
in a digital world in a very different
often unfortunately a two-dimensional
World which is not great but it's where
they are and I think we need to manage
that we also need to think about and
this is something I'm really passionate
about right now is there a way that
social media which has been so much the
cause I think of problems that we're
dealing with uh for youth how could we
could we turn that into the solution uh
are there ways to meet kids where they
are uh maybe that's on Discord maybe
that's in Roblox I don't know you know
where the best platforms are going to be
but there are some that are to do this
um you know I just saw this program with
Minecraft for kids who are um grieving
because of a loss of a parent are there
ways to take the kinds of Highly
addictive and engaging um platforms that
kids are on today and use those to
really give kids the skills they need to
be successful in in the 21st century
that sort of brain health skills I think
we ought to be thinking about that that
and we also ought to be thinking about
how we U reduce the toxicity in some of
these systems at the in the same way
part of why we failed uh in mental
health with so much to offer isn't that
um people don't have access to things
it's that we don't they don't engage and
that's where U I've gotten so interested
in technology because technology if or
whatever else it does it is incredibly
engaging Tik Tock is a genius at how to
engage your attention um we need to be
able to do that uh we need to be able to
use those principles to help people get
the stuff that helps and help the get
the things that allow them to flourish
uh we haven't done that and and yet I
think there's a lot of lot of
opportunity
there this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like changing while
leaving your window wide open gross you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy that's why I use expressvpn
it's super easy you hit a button and
then you just beam in best of all you
know no one can see what you're doing no
big tech companies no ad companies no
other companies why use expressvpn when
you go online it is just you and your
surfing no one can see it you know it's
the way to go because a bunch of big
companies say hey all of you high-end
consultants and spies use
expressvpn secure your online activity
by visiting expressvpn.com slang today
that's
expressvpn.com yangang and you can get
an extra 3 months free expressvpn.com
slang
you you know my my dream Tom is to have
uh you know a wellness allowance it's
like what's that like you know you you
doing this is going to make you happier
healthier sure go for it you you know I
mean like go ahead like pay pay for that
um that hike workout yoga
studio uh mix martial arts like whatever
the heck it
is go go ahead and uh um plug in
get some people place of purpose going
uh you know and and then you'd wind up
with all sorts of new offerings too um
because then people would be like oh
people dig this um right right now there
are so many things that you kind of want
to see in a given community that
unfortunately the market is supporting
less and less uh you know I think about
some of the studios in you know small
town in Upstate New York and then more
and more the kids are staying indoors
the kids are on their phones and like
slowly like the business dwindle
uh you know you you'd like uh that
business to be more robust because it'd
be a win for everyone who shows up uh
every day I actually think the public
good would be well served by that uh you
know it's like my my dream is to have
almost like a um and and this is this is
actually the dream for me I think that
our um our economy is going to wind up
undervaluing certain things
systematically and a lot of those things
are the things we want um and so uh
putting money into people's hands is one
way to get that to be more fully valued
but I think having another dimension and
so my my Wellness allowance like I'm
imagining essentially you get uh the
equivalent of like a a credit or another
currency that you can do whatever you
want with and it's use it or lose it so
it's like well I guess I got to use this
stuff someone takes it then then you
know you taking a bunch of credits you
redeem it etc etc so that's not that
complicated that could we could do that
like we could do that today right and
maybe we should as an experiment maybe
we should I mean there's some some very
cool stuff that's been done by he's no
longer at MIT he was there but he was
doing these experiments with um
providing a kind of Wellness credit to
um villages in Africa and looking at
their mental Wellness over time it's a
guy named Hans
hoser and or johanes hos Huffer um and
it was an extraordinary set of
experiments and she showed that the
effect size for giving people in this
case it was sort of a universal basic
income I think it was like
$1,200 that they were getting was
actually greater than uh than
Psychotherapy than medication then in
terms of their of their mental Wellness
um measures that were taken like 18
months later and he did this in uh
across several villages in Kenya and
Tanzania it's a very interesting set of
studies it's funny nobody ever writes
about it I think I was going to put it
into my book and I just couldn't fit it
in anywhere so I've just been an admirer
of his work but you know when you go
into the literature there's actually
quite a bit of stuff there that says
this stuff works we could do this this
isn't it it's simply taking things like
this to scale and um and and honestly to
your you know specifically to your point
with forward Andrew it it's about
leadership we need leadership that cares
about doing things that incentivize the
right kinds of behaviors and and I'm
afraid that hasn't been the case in most
places yeah if we fixed the incentives
all things are possible congratulations
on this phenomenal book healing our path
from mental illness to mental health so
Tom if people want to keep up with you
your work how can they best do so I've
got a website uh thomasin md.com that's
probably the easiest way is lots of
stuff on there there's a bunch of things
about the book on there um and I
actually do watch it pretty carefully so
I respond to most of what comes in what
people can actually talk to Tom that
that's incredible congratulations again
my friend I mean this is awesome work um
uh I hope that people take your vision
to Heart uh because there's so much more
we can do and uh you're right that there
is more and more attention being paid
because now it's undeniable I mean where
people are suffering from mental in ways
big and small the book says that about
40% of people are getting treatment
which means 60% are not um certainly if
you're listening to this and uh you
think you might need some help go get
some help I mean uh uh if you have
someone in your life who you think could
use some help try and get them some help
there's a lot we can do uh I saw a
counselor therapist when I was a
teenager thought it was awesome um and
uh thought like who wouldn't like to
talk to
somebody about themselves and hey if you
don't even want to talk to someone you
can probably even talk to an AI at this
point but talk to somebody uh and and
get yourself um hopefully in the good
Zone thank you Tom congratulations again
this is awesome thanks Andrew great
chatting with you take
care